Aujourd'hui, on va parler
d'un drôle de sujet.
Puisqu'on va parler du rire
Six faits hyper intéressants sur le rire du style :
Est-ce qu'on peut vraiment mourir de rire?
Est-ce qu'une épidémie de rire a vraiment
ravagé la Tanzanie
en 1962 pendant 6 mois?
Et pour le reste, un petit
peu de suspense quand même.
Parce que, mine de rien,
mes blagues et parfois celles
de Loïc vous font réagir en bien.
Mais parfois,
on va pas se mentir,
c'est la guerre dans les commentaires.
Alors d'ailleurs,
si vous voulez vraiment faire la guerre,
n'allez pas
dans les commentaires.
Pour ça, il y a le jeu Warpath,
qui sponsorise cette vidéo
et ce sponsoring, qui va
directement dans le projet,
le prochain énorme casse tête
qui sera à plus de 15 000 euros.
Sinon, c'est pas drôle.
On va jamais s'en sortir.
Loïc,
Générique !
Soldat de la guerre,
bienvenue en commentaire
Bienvenue sur WarPath
Un jeu de stratégie réaliste sur mobile,
un jeu gratuit, un jeu où vous pourrez
faire la guerre n'importe où, n'importe
quand et surtout sans blesser personne.
Parce que ça, quand même, c'est mieux.
Le but ultime, c'est de, très modestement,
dominer le monde avec des stratégies
d'alliance, des bâtiments, de la technologie.
Vous allez incarner un des dix
commandements historiques personnalisables
avec ses propres compétences.
Donc mon choix, moi personnellement,
se porterait sur Bloody Mary parce qu'elle
a quand même son nom,
son propre cocktail.
Et ça, c'est stylé, ça fait plaisir.
Dans le jeu, vous allez collecter du vrai
équipement historique
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
C'est ultra précis.
Le but du jeu, c'est de vous faire vivre
une immersion sur un
terrain réel à l'aide
de campagnes authentiques
et de véritables faits historiques.
Vous avez compris,
votre stratégie sera la manière la plus
importante pour gagner et donc aura
un impact en temps réel.
Les performances des combats auront
été optimisées
ainsi que les détails graphiques du jeu
et vous pourrez aller
très loin dans vos stratégies
avec des actions telles que "entourez",
"intercalez",
"bloquer la restriction de position"
ou alors,
jouer sur les points faibles
de vos ennemis.
Vous pourrez combattre
des joueurs ennemis du monde entier,
et peut être même, créer
des alliances
et vous faire des potes d'armée,
d'armée.... de jeu mobile,
mais d'armée quand même !
Pour télécharger Warpath,
rendez-vous dans la description
en suivant mon lien.
C'est pas mal soldat !
et merci... Warpath
Revenons sur un autre
sujet, plus joyeux, le rire.
Le rire, c'est un mécanisme naturel
qui est présent dans toutes les cultures,
à tout âge, dans toutes les langues.
C'est vraiment universel.
Avant de passer aux choses dingues
comme des chatouilles sur des rats,
(je vous raconte ça tout à l'heure)
je vais vous expliquer ce qui se passe
dans le cerveau quand vous riez.
D'abord, votre cortex préfrontal fait "diiing "
puisque c'est la zone qui est
en lien avec vos émotions,
vos muscles faciaux se contractent
dont, les zygomatiques
et votre diaphragme
se contracte également
et vous émettez des sons
donc un rire.
Puis vous relâchez complètement
votre corps
et ce relâchement
peut parfois poser
problème puisque vous pouvez
littéralement vous faire pipi dessus.
Ce n'est pas de ma faute...
Donc, si vous avez la vessie pleine
et que vous vous pliez en deux, il arrive
malheureusement ce qui peut arriver.
Mais alors pourquoi rit-on?
Et surtout,
est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose?
Robert Proving, spécialiste
du comportement humain et animal,
a démontré que l'on est 30%
plus susceptibles de rire
en présence de quelqu'un
que si on est
tout seul dans une pièce.
Et ça, ça signifie directement
que le rire est un mécanisme social.
Rire avec quelqu'un,
ça améliore la relation,
ça favorise une meilleure communication.
Rire, c'est se donner
un sentiment d'appartenance.
Et c'est pour ça qu'un spectacle,
un one-man show, vous semblera toujours
moins drôle en vidéo,
sur internet par exemple,
qu'en étant avec le public
dans une salle.
Et c'est aussi souvent pour cette
raison que le rire est communicatif.
Sophie Scott,
neuroscientifique à l'Université
de Londres,
explique que tout rire
active les neurones
miroirs dans le cerveau.
Vous connaissez les neurones miroirs,
on en a parlé plein
de fois sur cette chaîne.
Chez les animaux, le rire,
c'est plutôt un réflexe,
comme avec les chatouillements.
Si je chatouille,
je ris par réflexe.
Shimpei Ishiyama
et Michael Brecht,
chercheurs à Berlin,
ont mené une expérience
assez rigolote.
Pendant plusieurs mois,
ils ont chatouillé des rats.
C'est ça leur taf en fait...
En enregistrant leur réaction.
Les chercheurs expliquent que,
si on chatouille un jeune rat sur le ventre,
il agite ses petites pattes en l'air,
il couine avec un son aigu
et inaudible pour nous
il est visiblement hilare
et les enfants réagissent pareil
lorsqu'on les chatouille.
Il n'y a que les gloussements
qui diffèrent des ultrasons
qui sont produits par les rats.
Ce qui est encore plus dingue,
c'est qu'il faut que le rat soit
en confiance, pour qu'il se mette à rire.
Shimpei Ishiyama explique que les rats,
qui sont un peu timides, un peu réservés,
doivent d'abord s'habituer à sa présence
pendant quelques jours,
jusqu'à ce que leur
timidité s'estompe.
Et là, ils peuvent rire
quand il les chatouille.
Moi, je trouve ça fou
comme chez les humains.
Imaginez si vous prenez le bus,
et là, il y a dans le bus, comme ça,
et il y a un inconnu qui vous
chatouille les aisselles.
Vous allez trouver ça un peu chelou.
Vous allez juste être hyper mal à l'aise.
Ça ne va pas vraiment vous faire rire.
Par contre, si c'est votre meilleur ami
qui commence à vous chatouiller les pieds
dans le canapé, eh ben là,
ça chatouille mon gars.
Les chercheurs sont allés plus loin
en implantant des électrodes directement
dans le cerveau des rongeurs.
Ils ont localisé la zone exacte du cerveau
qui est sollicitée lors
des séances de chatouilles.
Il s'agit du cortex somato sensoriel,
qui est la partie du cerveau
qui répond au toucher sur la peau.
Et c'est ça qui déclenche la réaction.
D'autres scientifiques sont
encore assez sceptiques.
Le débat est partagé
sur le rire animalier.
Pour certains, il s'agirait de rire.
Et pour d'autres, il s'agirait juste d'une
manifestation de bien-être
et non véritablement d'un rire.
C'est quand même le bien-être, je trouve.
Ça marche.
Dans tous les cas, c'est sympa.
Là, vous n'êtes clairement pas prêt.
En Tanzanie, dans les années 60,
une épidémie de rire s'est propagée
dans tout le pays et jusque là,
vous allez me dire,
c'est quand même plus drôle
que l'épidémie qu'on vit actuellement.
Mais, en vrai,
ce n'était pas vraiment fun.
Le 30 janvier 1962,
dans un pensionnat pour jeunes filles
à Kashasha,
trois jeunes écolières ont
commencé à se comporter
de manière un peu étrange.
Elles ont eu des crises
de fou rire incontrôlables,
mêlées à des crises de larmes.
Elles étaient hyper agitées,
voire parfois violentes,
et elles essayaient de s'arrêter
mais elles n'y arrivaient pas.
Ces crises se sont propagées
dans toute leur école
... et ce n'est pas le genre :
"la petite crise de fou
rire de cinq minutes"...
Là, ça a duré de quelques heures,
à une quinzaine de jours,
et les enseignants, eux,
n'étaient pas du tout touchés.
Il n'y a que les enfants qui ont été
victimes.
Incapable de gérer ça,
l'école a fermé le 18 mars 1962 et ce
phénomène a commencé à s'étendre
de village en village, où les écoles
fermaient les unes après les autres.
Cette épidémie a duré plus de six mois.
Les médecins ont tenté de comprendre
en faisant plein plein d'examens différents :
prise de sang,
ponction lombaire, etc.
Ça n'a rien donné.
Il n'y a pas de cause infectieuse.
Je sais que ce que je raconte
ça paraît fou, mais c'est réel !
Pour les scientifiques,
il s'agit d'un phénomène d'hystérie collective
qui a été provoqué
par un stress intense.
Et il y a le sociologue Robert Bartholomew
et le psychiatre Simon Wessely,
qui expliquent que de nombreuses épidémies
de rire sont nées dans les années 60-70
dans les pays d'Afrique centrale
et de l'Est.
Et cela pourrait être dû à l'influence
du contexte politique,
qui s'expliquerait aussi,
par le fait que les enfants
ont fait face à de gros
conflits émotionnels personnels.
C'est des enfants qui étaient élevés
dans des milieux traditionnels,
mais exposés à des idées complètement
différentes quand ils allaient à l'école.
Il existe aussi le rire prodromique.
Alors là, c'est souvent le cas
dans des maladies comme Parkinson,
où le rire est incontrôlable.
C'est un rire pathologique qui est
dû à un dysfonctionnement cérébral.
Le rire incontrôlable peut être aussi,
malheureusement,
annonciateur d'un AVC proche
donc, faire attention,
mais en même temps,
ne stressez pas à chaque fou rire.
Ça ne va pas pour autant
dire que vous êtes malade.
Tout va bien !
Avant de vérifier si on peut vraiment
mourir de rire parce qu'on
va avoir ça juste après.
Parlons de Jennifer Aaker,
et Naomi Bagdonas,
qui ont étudié 1,4 million de personnes,
dans 166 pays différents,
pour conclure qu'à partir de l'âge de 23 ans,
on rit beaucoup moins.
Dommage.
Elles ont constaté un fait
qui va beaucoup vous surprendre.
Le quatrième fait va vous surprendre.
Les enfants de 4 ans rient environ 300 fois par jour,
alors qu'un adulte de 40 ans rit
environ 300 fois en dix semaines.
En gros, un adulte, ça rit entre trois
et quatre fois par jour.
Mais pourquoi 23 ans?
Parce que c'est l'âge moyen
auquel les gens commencent à entrer
dans le monde professionnel.
Et Jennifer et Naomi considèrent
que nous devenons, à ce moment là,
des personnes plus sérieuses
dans un monde professionnel
où l'humour est sous exploité.
Donc... faites des blagues au boulot,
mais des bonnes !
Alors, est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment mourir de rire?
La réponse, c'est que je parle
de mourir de rire au sens propre.
Une crise de rire peut causer une asphyxie
et/ou un arrêt cardiaque.
Des chercheurs
du City Hospital Birmingham,
au Royaume-Uni,
ont publié une étude
dans le British Medical Journal
en expliquant que le rire peut
aussi comporter des risques.
Et c'est arrivé à un médecin danois
qui est mort en pleine séance de cinéma
devant le film "Un poisson nommé Wanda".
Son cœur avait battu tellement fort,
entre 250 et 500 battements par minute,
et ça a provoqué un arrêt cardiaque direct.
Petite fun fact :
les chatouilles étaient utilisées
comme moyen de torture,
notamment en Chine impériale,
où cette technique était employée
contre les nobles parce qu'elle
laissait pas de traces visibles.
Mais elle faisait céder...
aussi bien que la douleur !
Je sais que ce n'est pas une surprise,
je pense que vous le savez,
mais est-ce que vous savez pourquoi
on ne peut pas vraiment se
chatouiller soi même?
En fait, c'est un mécanisme
de protection, tout simplement.
Si ce mécanisme n'existait pas,
cela poserait des gros problèmes
dans la vie de tous les jours puisque
le moindre contact,
par exemple les vêtements
qui frottent contre votre bras,
ça pourrait vous déclencher
un fou rire un peu gênant.
Des chercheurs de l'Université
de Londres
ont fait deux expériences
sur une quinzaine de volontaires
qui étaient sous IRM.
Première expérience
se laisser chatouiller le creux de la main
par une éponge qui est tenue par un robot.
Et là, le résultat est assez clair,
les sujets étaient sensibles aux chatouilles
et la zone du cortex somato sensoriel,
comme chez les rats,
s'activait.
Deuxième expérience.
Le but était de se chatouiller soi-même
en actionnant le robot de son propre gré.
C'est toujours le robot qui a l'éponge,
mais c'est le volontaire
qui actionne le robot.
Là, pas de surprise.
Zéro réaction.
Et pourtant, le cortex, somato-
sensoriel, était toujours activé.
Alors, on peut se demander pourquoi?
Eh bien, parce que le cervelet
s'activait aussi.
Et en gros, le cervelet dit
au reste du corps du cerveau
de ne pas
prendre en compte les sensations.
Euh, c'est bon, c'est normal,
c'est nous qu'on fait ça.
Du coup, ça va !
Cette sensation là, du coup,
est inutile puisque c'est
vous-même qui la provoquez.
La première personne à avoir étudié
les vertus du rire sur la santé est
Norman Cousins,
un journaliste américain.
Et pourtant, il n'a pas l'air
de vouloir rigoler sur la photo.
Norman était atteint d'une
maladie pas très sympa.
La spondylarthrite ankylosante.
Alors, c'est quoi?
C'est une maladie qui atteint surtout
la colonne vertébrale et le bas du dos.
Il a décidé d'entreprendre
une thérapie par le rire.
Et aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître, au bout de trois semaines,
il ne ressentait plus de douleur.
Le rire créé de l'endorphine,
L'endorphine étant un antidouleur naturel
sécrété par le cerveau.
C'est ce qu'on appelle ,
une substance endogène.
Lorsque vous riez,
vos muscles se détendent
votre pression artérielle diminue,
votre sang s'oxygène
et votre
système immunitaire est renforcé.
Quand on rit, ça provoque
une contraction du diaphragme.
Cette contraction,
elle stimule les organes comme le foie,
la rate, l'estomac et l'intestin.
C'est bon pour le corps.
Un autre fait intéressant a été
soulevé par des chercheurs américains.
Il a été démontré que l'humour aurait
les mêmes effets qu'une drogue.
Ils ont mené une petite étude parce
qu'il n'y avait que 16 volontaires.
Ces derniers sont passés sous un IRM aussi
et les chercheurs ont
montré des illustrations volontaires.
Il y en a certaines qui pouvaient susciter
le rire, quasiment à coup sûr,
et d'autres
qui n'était pas drôle du tout.
Et le résultat qui a été observé,
c'est que lorsque des volontaires
observaient les images qui étaient
vraiment très drôles,
le centre de la récompense dans leur
cerveau gauche s'activait.
Et ça, c'est une zone,
le centre de la récompense,
qui libère de la dopamine,
donc une sensation de plaisir.
Et cette stimulation est
proche de la prise de drogue.
Cette découverte est intéressant parce
que elle va permettre à la science
de trouver, peut être, de nouveaux
antidépresseurs.
Aujourd'hui, il existe pas moins de 5 000
écoles du rire dans le monde entier.
Vous vous retrouvez avec des gens
et vous riez volontairement.
Alors dit comme ça, ça paraît chelou,
mais la science approuve cette pratique.
Sinon, je voulais conclure
par un truc un peu plus fun.
Ça nous est déjà tous arrivé de rire
dans une situation alors que ce
n'était pas du tout le moment...
Limite ça devient incontrôlable parce que vous
savez que ce n'est pas le bon moment pour rire
et j'aimerais que vous
me racontiez, en commentaire,
votre fou rire nerveux
le plus gênant ou le plus gros ...
Allez y!
Lâchez vous!
Si vous me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
si vous me connaissez,
pas Sébastien, pas Olivier.
Vous pouvez vous abonner
en cliquant là
ou appuyer sur la cloche.
Et puis laissez un like,
parce que ça soutient bien la vidéo.
Ici, je vous mets deux autres vidéos,
une vidéo sur six choses que vous
ne saviez pas sur le QI.
Et là, une vidéo sur six bêtes,
étonnamment féroces,
étonnamment flippantes,
qui ont étonnamment existé en France.
Prenez soin de vous!
A très bientôt
Tchao !!